à cause de qui à cause de quoi
la catastrophe de beyrouth et ces
explosions titanesque semble être
l'aboutissement sous forme de métaphore
de la situation dans laquelle s'enlise
le liban depuis plusieurs mois et même
plusieurs années novembre 2013 les
autorités portuaires de beyrouth saisi
une cargaison sur un bateau battant
pavillon moldave parti de géorgie à
destination du mozambique le russe ce
dernier avait accosté à beyrouth en
raison de problèmes techniques selon le
cabinet d'avocats libanais barreau
d'iéna sociales qui représentent
l'équipage du bateau les autorités
portuaires des charges d'alors 2007 150
tonnes de nitrate d'ammonium est les
stocks dans un entrepôt délabré aux murs
fissurés selon des responsables libanais
tandis que le rose us après le lancement
de poursuites contre le propriétaire
dont le nom reste inconnu
fini par couler au port de beyrouth en
2018 la suite
[Musique]
on la connaît selon une enquête menée
par l'ogc nice crimecraft project
consortium de journalistes
d'investigation
le propriétaire du rose us seraient
charalambos manoli à magna du transport
maritime chypriote
ce dernier dément toujours toute
implication le capitaine du navire en
revanche avaient été identifiés presque
aussitôt après l'explosion et s'était
exprimé dans les médias
il s'agit d'un citoyen russe boris
prokofiev selon lui il ne fait aucun
doute des autorités portuaires
son comble les autorités de beyrouth
savait très bien qu'il s'agissait d'une
cargaison dangereuse il aurait fallu
l'évacuer
ils ont choisi de saisir le navire et sa
cargaison pour se faire de l'argent
évidemment mais s'ils avaient su qu'une
catastrophe arriverait il n'aurait
jamais fait cela la cargaison était
dangereuse elle pouvait exploser à tout
moment
il le savait autorités portuaires
corrompu donc mais encore dans une
longue tribune publiée dans le quotidien
libération
le chercheur et écrivain franco libanais
gilbert achcar explique que quelles que
soient les circonstances dans lesquelles
ces explosions soit survenu qu'elles
soient accidentelles délibéré qu'elle
provienne d'un premier incendie dans un
dépôt d'armement adjacent ou simplement
de feu d'artifice la responsabilité
d'avoir laissé 2007 150 tonnes de
nitrate d'ammonium hautement explosifs
entreposés au coeur d'une ville six
années durant à combat l'ensemble de la
classe dirigeante libanaise présidents
de la république premiers ministres
ministres des transports chefs des
principaux appareils de sécurité
administrateurs du port hesbollah
sont à blâmer dans cette catastrophe car
tous ont leur part de responsabilité
dans la manière dont le liban s'enlise
dans la corruption et la stagnation
politique
selon gilbert achcar il s'agit d'une
conséquence logique de l'histoire du
pays marquée par l'effondrement de
l'économie libanaise cela fait 30 ans en
effet que le liban s'est engagée sur la
voie de la reconstruction après quinze
années de guerre civile et
internationales et dans un contexte
mondial dominé par le néolibéralisme
victime avant 1975 l'année du début de
la guerre le liban était déjà réputé
pour être un des paradis fiscaux de la
planète un pays de capitalisme sauvage
dont le secret bancaire et les avantages
fiscaux faisait un terrain idéal pour le
blanchiment d'argent sale la fuite de
capitaux et toutes sortes de trafics
dans un environnement régional d'états
dictatoriaux fin septembre emmanuel
macron qui s'est érigée depuis deux mois
en grand médiateur de la question
libanaise
ce qui lui a offert un énième coup de
projecteur sur la scène internationale
alors qu'il est en difficulté dans son
propre pays affirmait j'ai honte pour
les dirigeants libanais et ce système de
corruption où tout le monde se tient
parce que tout le monde a touché
aujourd'hui quelques dizaines de
personnes sont en train de faire tomber
un pays dans le climat étouffant de
colère populaire au liban certains ont
pu espérer que cette double explosion en
entraînerait une autre politique cette
fois appuyée par une forte pression
internationale organisation d'élections
sur la base d'une nouvelle loi
électorale
formation d'un nouveau gouvernement qui
se libérait de l' influence de la classe
dirigeante traditionnelle mais après
l'échec cuisant du premier ministre a
formé un nouveau gouvernement le liban
s'enfonce de plus en plus dans
l'incertitude et la division le port de
beyrouth n'est plus l explosion
politique n'a pas eu lieu